l'histoire mais je sais c'est très
marrant il était une fois dans la ville
de quoi non en grèce dans la ville de
anglais n'existe pas l'asile de ce que
l'on peut l'imaginer une réunion sur
l'invention du cheval de troie deux fois
voilà je savais messieurs je déclare
ouverte la 73e réunion pour choisir le
truc de 3 alors on fait quel animal et
pourquoi un animal non mais parce qu'on
a validé sa la semaine dernière mercredi
n'était pas là donc c'est un animal
qu'on fait pour moi non en légumes c'est
bien aussi par exemple
aussi si une tomate non tiens fruits la
tomate écoute on a tranché la dernière
fois un animal en bois s'est le mieux ok
je vois qu'on n'a pas besoin de moi je
me casse
non maintenant aller revient on en parle
à mon choisy l'animal ensemble je
reviens si on fait une tortue j'aime
bien une tortue c'est bien ça ressemble
un peu à une tomate en plus mais en
fruits donc ça ferait la tortue de 3
c'est pas terrible comme non mais c'est
vrai du pur une tortue j'ai oit l'aigle
de 3 1 elle s'est tellement classe en
plus on agite bien les y est l'on peut
voler si si on agite vite comme ça avec
de l'élan qu'il t'a 10 mois et on peut
pas
les oiseaux ils le font les oiseaux ne
sont pas en bois et arrêtent non un
aigle netgem peau c'est rouge auraient
regardé geof des aigles en bois en
cadeau et pas de soucis alors donne
moins trois animaux et ont choisi dedans
et pas facile le lapin le cheval et la
mouche la mouche la mouche
pourtant qu'à d'autres tops des mouches
ok je retiens la mouche moi moi j'ai une
idée une girafe n'en faudrait construire
des escaliers bah je vais faire pipi
mais c'est qui lui c'est le fils de
l'autre là avec les trucs sur obligé de
le garder ok ok donc y nord-est
il nous reste le lapin et le cheval j'ai
fais pipi la mouche
ok alors c'est parti pour le cheval il
peut être couleur tomates
non il sera cooller cheval qu'on sert à
deux pas du tout si aussi au zizi et tu
le sais ah oui tu ne sers 10 ans as tu
du genre ou regardez moi je garantis
la mouche
ok adjugée pour le cheval de troie le
nom est super classe on pourra mettre
pleins de soldats dedans et on n'aura
qu'à dire c'est un cadeau comme celle de
mettront dans leur village 1
il accepte tout et c'est gratuit c'est
crevard de troyens ouais ouais ça
c'était raciste allawi
je veux partir on se voit mardi oui et
en attendant craie pour tout le monde
waouh sauf moi je me cache un peu plus
et c'est ainsi que débute à la
construction du cheval de troie en tout
cas d'après des chaussettes